his name is Thomas sadoski and he is one
of the stars of Tomi on CBS that airs
Thursdays at 10:00 Eastern Time good to
see you Thomas sadoski good to see you
back you been good great yeah I've been
great how'd you handle this Ravens
season let's get rid of I mean I was I
was thrilled I was also terrified the
instant we got to the play first of all
I mean Lamar Jackson single-handedly
changing the game revolutionising you
know the way the game is played right
now the single most exciting athlete
I've seen in football since Barry
Sanders like every time he touches the
ball you just need something your heart
rate goes up and you're like what's
gonna happen next and as a fan of the
Ravens the most terrifying player like
every time he took off outside the
pocket I was like oh god no please down
right down and I I spent the season just
like yo-yoing back and forth between
those things and then when I saw the
draw for the playoffs and saw that we
had Tennessee and people were like oh
man we're gonna stop Kansas haven't I
said the instant the instant I saw
Tennessee I said we got a problem they
just had a hold they played for the
Ravens played in in the early 2000s
right and beat us with it because we
didn't we don't have as right now the
defense we had Yahoo's well I guess
you'll probably never have that defense
again no one ever special but I think
you know what the Ravens do need is one
more well at least a viable wide
receiver threat you know I know I like
the number of tight ends that they have
yeah and Hollywood Brown was terrific in
week one and then he was great out here
in Los Angeles when he caught several of
the of the five touchdowns by Lamar he's
he's a kid you know Willie Snead you
know we just III think the Ravens if
they could add some sort of physical
Beast wide receiver trade up in and grab
Jefferson or somebody right or or get
either a names someone from Alabama
pretty much know seriously if you can
train if you can get up that high I
don't think you can try but they're so
deep that the wide receiving class that
we're gonna see at the combine next week
sit back on bigots Thursday night you'll
see them all and it's supposed to be
incredible but just that would be a
great new shiny absolutely would love to
see it we've done that before you know
put all of our faith in drafting a first
round wide receiver shod Perriman comes
to mind that hasn't panned out what I'm
most interested in seeing the Ravens do
is build the interior offensive line and
build their defense back up because
Lamar Jackson Ingram even with the
weapons they have on the outside right
now and the tight end scheme that
they're using I think can be a real
force in the NFL but it's in as much as
the game is changing there are certain
aspects of it that you absolutely have
to get into the playoffs play old school
style football in order to win just like
Tennessee did like they proved it again
and again and again and again and and
that's why Kansas City is so amazing
throughout the course of the year right
they had those sort of fundamental
things unlock and that's a place where
the Ravens have been shaky the last few
years and definitely worth it what has
it been like for you to have an MVP
quarterback with all due respect to Joe
Flacco and by the way you are here on
the Rich Eisen show by saying with all
due respect you can say anything you
want that's disrespectful after that
sure no absalom but you know Joe had an
incredible playoff run the year that the
Ravens won the Super Bowl with Flacco
certainly where the heap bet on himself
and that is always pressure-filled need
a great year I'm done trying to set up
the fact that I did say something
disrespectful for Joe but what was it
like to have from week one week 16 for
the probably the first time in your
phantom a quarterback that was clearly
far and away the best quarterback in the
NFL for playing seasons well it's so fun
I had to have been I it was so fun
god I mean I you know I sort of flashed
back to like what it must have been like
for for Falcons fans in the early you
know Mike Vick days right and and the
Eagles fans during the Randall
Cunningham days and like you know I just
sort of vaguely remember like what
Colorado buffalo fans were like you know
during the Kordell Stewart year you know
the lake the like ever they just they
were walking on air and totally thrilled
and everyone wanted to watch their games
right because of everything that was
going on in
just going yeah yeah yeah those are our
guys yeah that's our guy that's our dude
and then you get to see the rest of the
of the organization and what's so
beautiful about the Ravens is that
there'd like such a perfect symbiosis
with the city like that organization
particularly this team as it existed
last year right fits that city so well
that it was just it was thrilling it was
thrilling to see the fans get that sort
of opportunity because it was it was
cool Thomas sadoski here on the Rich
Eisen show and you just mentioned you
know obviously multi-faceted
quarterbacks who can run show etc
Brockman a New England fan over there
you've had a quarterback throw 50
touchdowns in the season I realized me
as a Jets fan what I got over here I
mean we're hoping Donald's that guy
quarterbacking would it take that add up
to 50 touchdowns it's a good question oh
I think maybe the last two Donald
campaign's Donald I don't even think he
does you know
Lamar had 36 this year alone yep and
then we perhaps had 14 in the has 36
career touchdown passes peace by the way
one of the truly nicest guys I've ever
met Sam darn what did you meet Santa we
were at a Rangers game together okay and
one of the legitimately nicest guys I've
ever met
it couldn't be nicer every single time I
met I'd it's really truly funny
Laidback great dude hey first thing he
did when he was drafted by the Jets and
he showed up in New Jersey for his press
conference he visited a Children's
Hospital he's a good man like this is
the stuff that he did yeah when he first
started in the NFL we are supposed to be
you know a big man on campus I'm the
third overall pick and I'm a mr. New
York now doesn't carry himself like that
at all
I would just love for him to not get
mononucleosis sure I would like him to
stay healthy outside of the
mononucleosis and I would like him to
you know I just I I'm pointing out just
like I've never had a football fandom
year were quarterback week one
spectacular neither had I and then week
16 is the MVP it's truly it's true I
mean you know as you can talk about you
know being a pads man it is real
mmm-hmm like it takes so much pressure
off like you really can just sit back
and enjoy yourself right during these
games I mean unless it's Lamar Jackson
he gets outside of the pot seconds and
then you get you know the minutes in
between plays you know alright and then
it gets outside the pocket again and a
god oh dear Cup but you know I
first of all watching that kid throw
yeah I know he's amazing and the fact
that he should have you know when he got
to the combine we can you know obviously
rehash history that let's see how fast
he can run I don't know if he can throw
he's runners to runner he's not a
quarterback and now he's the MVP of the
NFL it really is amazing
I've got Thomas sadoski of Tommy on CBS
right here in the Rich Eisen show when
you're on life and pieces there were
some athletes who came on right yet Kurt
Warner we had did Marshall Marshall came
on ok yeah and I mean the thing that's
hilarious about those dudes is that like
they're still so competitive all these
years later tell me about this like we
had Marsh come on we had we had him come
on and after Warner had been on yes and
and we were talking to - Marshall and
Eric Dickerson was there and we were
good yeah yeah and we were talking to -
Faulk and we were saying yeah we had
Warner on whatever and he was like oh
yeah yeah Curt Curt he was telling us
stories about him which were hilarious
just in and of himself but then he sort
of got quiet for a second and he got
real serious look on his face and he
looked over at us and he was like am i
doing better than him does that sound
like him legitimately terrifying to
answer that question so he directed that
at you there was a group of us always me
Colin Hanks and Dan Baca Dahl and we
were standing there and he asked all of
us and every you could see like three
grown men all simultaneously just pucker
it's like everyone's just like yeah and
you know because you didn't want to say
yes mmm and have water come back of
course and you didn't want to say no
because Marshall Fogg is standing in
front of you so what did you do do you
remember we
I I didn't say anything I did what I do
when I'm confronted with situations and
I laughed like an idiot and I went to
craft services and I wouldn't got some
skittles movie I just put like I put
that turn in Hanks his pocket here you
go buddy you you you handle this one so
was he better than current I can't
answer thirdly deep bowl of peppermint
lifesavers in our green room
there's dad's like an undertow if you it
is shopping it has its own it sort of it
has its own gravitational pull oh man so
you are now in CBS's Tommy yeah it's not
your first rodeo with Edie Falco correct
you legit did a show together on
Broadway me and Edie and Ben Stiller and
Jennifer Jason Leigh and Alison Pill
Christopher Abbott like we had this just
like ridiculous sort of embarrassment of
riches the house of blue leaves correct
yeah and was she on The Sopranos at that
point in time no no this is nurse Jackie
okay and and we you know we just we had
a blast she's I mean she's easily easily
easily one of our best actors that's out
there working but I agree he's also an
unbelievable human being we you know so
professional and so down to earth
which is the complete opposite of me and
Stiller when we're together so I
actually feel sorry for talking about
that show like I don't bring it up
around her anymore you know hey man
remember that time when we were on
Broadway together and I made your life
miserable because you were trying to do
really hard delicate like finely tuned
work on stage right Broadway and Stiller
and I were both facing upstage because
we were making each other laugh so much
is that really what's going on yeah no
we were terrible this is Broadway Manor
it's nama stewed it's not my fault it's
Ben Stiller what am I supposed to do you
like I walk out on stage I don't know
what his problem was but there was
something about like when this
second act starts it starts with me
sitting in a chair like weeping my eyes
out and been sort of standing there
uncomfortably going oh it's gonna be
okay
and there was something about the idea
of me sitting in this chair weeping
hysterically that Ben thought was the
funniest thing in the world hi I don't
know because he's twisted because he's
sick because because because he liked
making my life hell uh-huh so Ben would
be standing there going like trying to
be really serious and then we would
catch each other's eyes and it would
just something would happen and the next
thing I know I'm spending the next five
minutes just enough stage laughing right
but making trying to make it look like
I'm weeping you know any mean and Ben's
wandering around with that Stiller smirk
and we can't even look at each other
which is a real problem this is like
stuff that I did with a substitute
teacher
like the fourth grade you're doing this
on Broadway yeah okay but it's also I
will tell you that it's a it's a weird
experience yeah it's a weird experience
with that whole show was a weird
experience I remember there was one
night because Ben draws like very
interesting fans and like really people
have like very strange strong reactions
to Ben okay and there was there was this
moment in the show were like this this
explosion goes off onstage and he takes
Christopher Abbott and like they duck
down on to like one knee right at the
edge of the stage like right downstage
by the audience and it's right before
the lights go out at the end of the
first act and he comes off stage one
night and he looks at me comes knocks on
my dressing room door and I'm like
what's up man and he looks at me and he
goes the bomb went off I took Chris I
got down I kneeled down some lady in the
front row stood up and went like hit his
head and turned to her friend and when I
touched him like she she broke the wall
she literally reached across this man in
the head like was trying to touch him
but was they had to reach so far that
she like hit him it made a sound he
looked at her and all all he heard was
her turned back to a friend and go I
touched him
was she ejected from the theatre I don't
know I ain't touching a baseball and
playin like you know Yankee Stadium on
Broadway
well sort of it's also sort of like
reaching across and smacking Derek Jeter
on the ass right while he's doing the
flip right awkward Giambi might have
been safe he was out sorry Thomas
sadoski here on the Rich Eisen show and
now let's talk about the current show
you're doing with Edie Falco is playing
the first-ever female chief of police
from Los Angeles she's Tommy because
it's a play on her last two characters
last name of Thomas Wright you play the
mayor play the mayor of this show
what are you liking about this program
brother I mean I get to work with Edie
Falco also uh the guy who created the
show Paul Attanasio wrote Donnie Brasco
and quiz show which are two of my
favorite movies of all time and you know
having an opportunity to work with with
Edie with Paul frankly with like this
crew that we have you know not only I
just look amazing cast of like theater
actors that I've known for years and
years and years some of my oldest and
dearest friends Michael Chernus who is
from my money one of the best actors
that's working out there right now and
just an absolute sweetheart of a guy and
like so many amazing cast members but
this brilliant crew Edie brought in like
so many people from The Sopranos and
there's Jackie so it's just like a big
family and we just had a blast man you
know and to get to work with her and to
have fun you know playing a kind of a
smarmy politician it's great isn't that
an oxymoron summary politician there's a
sort of redundancy yeah yeah I don't
know that it yeah exactly you know who
decided to part your hair on the side
food for the mayoral row is that that
was a decision it's immediate decision
was a mutual decision that was done in
the hair and makeup room I would they
were like well it needs to be you need
to look a little bit fresh like yeah
let's partner on the side because that
makes me uncomfortable okay and right
now you trying to have the gavin newsom
gubernatorial hairstyle northern
california and you do
yes like right I'm your I'm your
governor that's right here right with
the point in the wink and then the
mayoral one you've got like the parting
of the sodding right you know the City
of Angels here right right on it yeah
you know trying to be a little bit more
corporate hmm you know I know and and I
and I think that that's uh I see it yeah
I mean we there was a couple of ways we
could have gone with it and I decided
this is god bless her you have an option
some of us don't this is all we got this
was also an option what could have done
what this yeah the colonel Tom the well
you know what I could aye aye aye
I call it distinguished usually I call
it ready for aerodynamics as I'm making
my run next week for st. you are making
good luck with that thank you sir it is
really truly one of the best things that
happens in the football so you're a good
dude for saying that no no it really I
mean it genuinely has become a highlight
of the season
I'm not kidding like athletes get into
it and it's for the literally could not
be for a better car thanks man and like
the fact that you're raising awareness
doing that and and everybody it's just
sort of a testament to you that like
everyone is so into it and has such a
good time with it that you know like
you're obviously a great dude for doing
it and everybody believes in the cause
so much and it's become like this moment
in the football season that everybody's
like alright it is supposed to be about
having a good time yeah and you can
actually do good for people while having
a good time Thomas that means a lot and
then you know you you as somebody who
knows about what it's like to perform
under pressure obviously you know oh
well know the guy the guy who always
reviews if you will my run and my style
is none other than Deion Sanders yeah
and he he doesn't shy away from from
saying what's on his mind
yeah yeah and so I gotta have come
correct I hope I hope to run very fast I
hope you do too
thanks brother yeah and congrats on
Tommy good luck with that and let's come
back any time you want a pleasure man
things got it at Thomas sadoski
on Twitter there's an underscore between
the memes on Instagram
Tommy is on CBS Thursdays at 10:00
Eastern Time for more of the Rich Eisen
show
tuned to audience channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app